le port du masque n'est plus obligatoire
ce n'est plus qu'une recommandation
désormais c'est facultatif en outre à
moscou toutes les restrictions liées au
corps un habit russe pour les
entreprises et dans le secteur des
services sont levés le centre de
recherche gamaleya c'est ici que le
premier vaccin contre le coc vide 19 a
été créé et est officiellement
enregistrés est qu un moyen efficace a
été élaboré pour sauver les patients
gravement atteints du coït 19 la
transfusion de plasma
les anticorps commence à se développer
14 15 20 jours après l'infection
pendant ce temps de nombreux agents
pathogènes ont le temps de se multiplier
et dieu nous protège de nous tuer si
vous injecter du plasma contenant des
anticorps deux trois dix jours après la
contamination de ces anticorps commence
à interagir avec le virus pathogène est
ce donc cela offre un peu de répit aux
malades et lui permet de développer ses
propres anticorps l'homme qui a inventé
cette méthode et a fait de nombreuses
découvertes en virologie et en
immunologie s'appelait lève zilber son
nom pourrait être annoncée dans cette
salle au même titre que d'autres
lauréats du prix nobel dont les
découvertes se base largement sur ces
travaux mais le prix nobel ne peut être
attribué à titre posthume
au lieu d honneur pour sa première
découverte lève zilber a été arrêté au
cours de sa vie il a été arrêté trois
fois et même en détention il a continué
à faire des recherches pour le bien de
l'état soviétique zilber a passé au
total de huit ans en prison et dans les
camps où il a tenu grâce à la fermeté de
son caractère et à l'amour de ses
proches
c'était un grand chercheur un grand
homme un homme au destin tragique sous
toit c'était une personnalité incroyable
quand il apparaissait quelque part dans
n'importe quelle société
tout commençait à tourner autour de lui
en permanence plusieurs prix nobel ont
été attribués à des gens qui se basait
sur les théories viraux génétique de
zilber en travaillant dans la taïga
il a découvert l'étiologie de
l'encéphalite à tiques et tout ce qui
est lié à cette maladie
et après ça la prison c'était horrible
mais il était exceptionnellement
résistants on l'a toujours admiré
[Musique]
non il n'y aura pas d'épidémie de peste
pour l'amour de dieu
tout d'abord la situation est sous
contrôle et en outre la peste ça se
traite
si les poumons sont affectées c'est une
peste pulmonaire si les ganglions
lymphatiques sont affectés qui le
grossiste qu'ils ressemblent à des bouge
beaucoup associent la peste au moyen âge
mais des épidémies de peste ont toujours
eu lieu en urss les informations sur les
épidémies de peste ont été classifiés ce
qui imposait d'énormes responsabilités à
ceux qui le combattaient lève zilber a
été arrêté en 1930
c'était ses trois premiers mois de
prison il a été accusé de sabotage peu
après l'élimination de l'épidémie de
peste en azerbaïdjan
[Musique]
une nuit le commissaire à la santé de
l'azerbaïdjan a appelé chili a dit que
plusieurs cas de peste avaient été
signalés dans la ville d'à d'hôtes et
qu'il fallait se rendre d'urgence au
foyer épidémique avec le personnel et il
ya autre chose ajoute at il écrivait
minerais au lieu de peste dans tous les
rapports l'équipe épidémiologique est
parti en toute hâte et à l'arrivée sur
les lieux
il s'est avéré que seul gilbert avait
des gants en caoutchouc
c'était une chose rare malgré les
risques d'infection il les a donnés à
ses assistants city il devait protéger
ses employés en leur donnant tout ce
dont ils avaient besoin pour travailler
dans la boîte et la l'instant je dirais
le professionnalisme a dépassé tous les
autres instincts de l'homme même
l'instinct de survie
la peste et et pulmonaires elle peut
être éliminés immédiatement il suffit
d'interrompre le contact du patient avec
les individus en bonne santé et biseau
les ceux qui ont déjà été en contact
tout cela a été fait rapidement
cependant à les deuxièmes et troisièmes
foyers sont apparus
un soir un agent du nkvd est venu me
voir il y à des saboteurs étrangers il
dissèque les cadavres de pestiféré à des
couples le coeur et le foie et répandre
la maladie avec pouvez vous organiser
immédiatement l'exhumation et l'examen
de toutes les sépultures
il faudra le faire en secret la nuit
parce que la population considère à cela
comme une profanation de tombes et des
troubles pourraient commencer
tout cela semble être une sorte de
fantasmagorie délirante sur les dix
tombes ouvertes cette nuit trois
cadavres ont été retrouvés la tête
coupée sans coeur ni fois
zilber doutait de la présence des
saboteurs derrière l'épidémie de peste
pourquoi des espions profondeur et ils
les tombes et découvrent et il les
organes de pestiférés si l'agent
pathogène de la peste pouvaient être
obtenus en laboratoire mais pour les
services de sécurité il s'agissait bien
d'une intervention étrangère et il était
risqué de les contredire
il était responsable de la validité et
de la qualité du résultat des études qui
lui avaient été confiées et cette
responsabilité professionnelle du plus
haut niveau
d'une part obligé à prendre des risques
et d'autre part justifié parfaitement
tous les risques
la population de la région est arriérée
religieuse le contact est difficile à
mener dans un des villages de montagne
et nous avons trouvé un homme qui
parlait un peu russe et il m'a dit qu'il
y avait une légende locale dans ces
régions si des familles entières
commencent à mourir cela signifie que le
premier mort est toujours en vie il faut
lui couper la tête et donner le coeur et
le foie à sa famille eh bien j'ai vu
clairement ce sombre tableau
nous avons fait se déshabiller toute la
population de la région l'avons déplacé
dans des tentes
heureusement qu'il faisait chaud des
équipes militaires spéciales ont traité
avec de la chloropicrine tous les
bâtiments et les vêtements absolument
tout après avoir maintenu toute la
région en isolement pendant deux
semaines nous avons éliminé la peste il
a été accueilli à bas coût avec les
honneurs mais a été envoyé en prison peu
de temps après
durant la décennie d'avant-guerre les
autorités soviétiques étaient préoccupés
par les menaces d'espionnage
les soupçons de sabotage ou d'activités
d'espionnage était fréquent
paradoxalement lève zilber a été accusé
d'avoir propagé la peste c'était la
première mais pas la dernière fois que
les collègues et proches de zilber
devait le sortir de prison et sa
première épouse
zinaida hier mme alieva a toujours été
la force motrice
[Musique]
et bien tout le monde connaît au moins
l'un des mariages d'élèves kurchatov
c'était avec zinaida hier moyer va que
la reine de la pénicilline russe c'était
une femme extraordinaire
les deux plus grandes réalisations de la
science médicale sont la création
d'antibiotiques et le développement de
vaccins
si l'exil beur était un scientifique de
premier plan dont le nom est inscrit à
jamais dans l'histoire du développement
de vaccins le nom de zinaida yarmal ieva
est entré dans l'histoire de la création
d'antibiotiques
ces deux génies ont probablement eu
beaucoup de mal à vivre ensemble
mais c'est dommage oui yarmal y va avait
deux passions la science et zilber
par passion pour la science elle sait
sciemment affectés avec des vibrions
cholériques forme pour l'efs gilbert
elle était prête à tout après leur
séparation
zinaida a été longtemps est gravement
malade ils ont plus tard créer une
nouvelle famille à chacun de leur côté
mais elle est venue à son secours chaque
fois qu'il s'est retrouvé derrière les
barreaux elle écrivait des lettres à des
hauts fonctionnaires du parti
persuadé d'éminentes personnalités de la
science et de la médecine de signer ces
lettres adressées à staline et béria
même la maire de laives zilber disait à
son frère méfie-toi de zina elle est
prête à te jeter dans la fournaise et
moi aussi et n'importe qui pour sortir
l'efs de là son premier emprisonnement
en azerbaïdjan a été le plus court il a
duré trois mois
les suivants seront plus longs et les
conditions de détention plus difficile
on n'a jamais de division des
générations pokal et tous les jeunes
venez célébrer son anniversaire
on était toujours ensemble alors quand
on commençait à danser il dansait avec
mes copines et lorsqu'il lui prenait
dans ses bras comme ça pas les fils
fondé devant lui je lui dis lèvres
qu'est-ce que vous avez 6 mais qu'est ce
que c'est il dit qu'est ce que c'est
voir deux coups de pied et les côte se
ressoude comme ça ressort tac
il a subi des fractures après sa 2ème
incarcération et des interrogatoires
dans les prisons de les fortes aux veaux
de la loubianka et de la boutyrka après
avoir refusé de témoigner durant l'
enquête zilber a été envoyé dans la
prison de haute sécurité de souk à 9 k
il a été accusé de trahison envers la
patrie d'espionnage et de sabotage et ce
peu après la découverte de l'agent
pathogène de l'encéphalite virale
d'abord la découverte de cet agent
pathogène un brillant travail
épidémiologique une recherche
épidémiologique remarquable qui a permis
non seulement d'identifier les
caractéristiques spécifiques de ce
pathogène mais aussi de décrire sa
nature les recherches ultérieures de ces
étudiants ont abouti à la création d'un
vaccin contre l'encéphalite virale mozy
tchenko le directeur de l'institut a
signalé au nkvd que les virologues sous
couvert de lutte contre l'encéphalite
avait contribué à sa propagation
la troïka organe extrajudiciaires de
poursuites criminelles qui a existé
entre 1937 et 1938 prononcer les
sentences en un temps record à la
condamner zilber à 10 ans de prison
sans droit de correspondance ses proches
ont de nouveau demandé sa libération
zinaida yarmal ieva devait prendre soin
de son ancien époux et de son mari lui
aussi scientifique est bien la vérité
est que après avoir rompu avec lèvres
elle a ensuite épousé un homme
merveilleux qui est mort plus tard en
prison ou en je me souviens pas mais ça
se voyait qu'elle aimait toujours relève
le mieux ce qu'elle a fait pour sauver
lève est incroyable est énuméré
zinaida et un maul ieva n'a pas pu
sauver son mari mes lèvres zilber a été
libéré en 1939
pendant des années son nom a été rayé
des publications liées à la découverte
de la tique encéphalique
il a réussi à passer un an en liberté
c'est dans cet institut clèves zilber a
mis en place le premier laboratoire
virologiques
il y a longtemps dit il ya papa j'ai eu
la chance de travailler avec une dame
âgée
lioubov malkovich c'était son ancien
employé sa célèbre collègue
les virus de la grippe pour mon été
isolé par trois savants britannique en
ils ont isolé ce virus chez des furets
africains blancs et deux ans plus tard
lève zilber elubo walkowicz ont isolé le
virus de la grippe chez les souris
blanche
c'était une première dans l'histoire des
chercheurs soviétiques
la souris est maintenant devenu un
étalon pour les études sur la grille car
aussi ridicule que cela puisse paraître
la ville se développe
de la même manière chez l'homme et chez
la souris seuls à l'accord au cours de
l'été 1940 ils sont venus arrêter le
professeur une troisième fois par
crainte pour ses proches il a nié avoir
une famille il ne s'était pas mariés
officiellement avec sa deuxième épouse
valeria qui s'est lié au va et tous deux
avaient été assez prudent pour donner à
leur fils le nom de famille de sa mère
lève n'en a jamais parlé il préféré
éluder ce sujet voilà ce que valait rien
raconté
l'eev ne voulait pas fonder une famille
et moi je dis non
on aura en fils important et puis
c'était pour ainsi dire une famille au
sens le plus noble du terme
[Musique]
c'est valeria qui a fondé cette fête
elle attendait toujours lèvres elle est
allée à la lubie un quart d'heure de jeu
tenant par la main leur petit lait elle
a dit qu'elle était sa femme alors même
qu'ils n'étaient pas mariés pour obtenir
l'autorisation de déposer des colis
elle n'a pas eu peur ce fut sa peine de
prison la plus dure zilber a failli
mourir d'épuisement un jour des années
après la libération du camp de petchora
des amis de la famille ont décidé de
présenter zilber un voisin
le célèbre réalisateur soviétique alexeï
dickie
[Musique]
alors ma mère comme et les usages a dit
alex et je vous présente lève notre et
tout à coup ils sont tombés dans les
bras l'un de l'autre ils sont restés
ainsi longtemps jours sans lever la tête
on ne comprenait pas ce qui se passait
enfin lève leva la tête et à 10 ultime
pexiora
[Musique]
de grandes personnalités de grande
envergure
dieu merci ils ont survécu
pato ensuite il nous a raconté au sujet
d'alexei le nouvel an prochain
vous imaginez bien que tout le monde
dans le camp était d'humeur sombre
ils ont été tous amenés aubin s'est tout
à coup à l'excès déclare et bien
maintenant je vais remonter le moral de
tout le monde il mais agile et sur son
corps nu du jardin et son linge à la
main marche à travers tout le camp vers
la caserne
vous imaginez ce fou rire quand ils se
sont retournés et l'asie je pense que je
vous ai bien remonter le moral pendant
sa première année à pécs aura l'un des
goulags
au delà du cercle polaire lève zilber
devait abattre des arbres mais le hasard
et sa formation médicale lui ont été
utiles
il a réussi l'accouchement de la femme
du directeur du camp et a été ensuite
chargé de l'infirmerie où il a créé un
petit laboratoire scientifique pour
lutter contre la pellagre et la vie
domino
aux rations les prisonniers recevait du
pain est une sorte de bouillon de
céréales c'est une nourriture à teneur 0
en vitamines lève alexandrowicz a
commencé à faire une décoction concentré
de mousse comme nous le savons
aujourd'hui elle contient beaucoup de
vitamines du complexe b
eh bien je ne sais pas combien de
prisonniers politiques il a sauvé le
brevet a été reçue
mais il n'en était pas titulaire bien
sûr s'étaient attribués ou nkvd pour
autant que je sache il y était écrit le
propriétaire du brevet on m'a appelé
pour me proposer de travailler dans un
laboratoire bactériologique j'ai refusé
la proposition a été réitéré deux fois
de plus ils m'ont fait passer deux
semaines avec des criminels on m'a de
nouveau convoqué j'ai encore refusé
il y avait des discussions sur la guerre
bactériologique à l'époque il avait peur
que quelque chose de ce genre puisse
survenir que ces recherches
scientifiques puissent être utilisés
contre l'humanité en fin de compte les
silver a été envoyé dans une scharrach
cas spécialisé dans la recherche
chimique
les chars hk sont des laboratoires
spéciaux propres au système du goulag où
les scientifiques soviétiques continuer
à travailler pour le pays dans les
années 30
beaucoup de scientifiques qui ont été
envoyés à l'instar de zilber après des
dénonciations ridicule
c'est alors que gilbert a élaboré la
conception viraux génétique de l'origine
du cancer
ces études sont d'une profondeur et
d'une ampleur extraordinaire et de mon
point de vue elle avait 20 25 ans d'
avance sur les capacités d'alors de la
science expérimentale
en cachette des gardiens et des
prisonniers qui l'aidait à attraper des
souris pour des expériences en échange
de tabac il a couché sur papier sa
théorie pour la transmettre au monde
extérieur par l'intermédiaire de son ex
épouse et de son frère benjamin cas
verrines
ils ont réussi à convaincre les
scientifiques les plus éminents du rss
de signer une lettre collective à
staline dans laquelle il affirmait qu'en
ces années de seconde guerre mondiale le
pays avait besoin
ma virologue de ce niveau en liberté
aujourd'hui tout le monde ne peut pas
comprendre ça c'était assez risqué ils
pouvaient tous être en danger
ils n'ont pas eu peur ou peut-être
avait-il peur mais ils ont tout de même
sorti de là c'était certainement un acte
héroïque
la lettre a fonctionné staline a ordonné
la libération du professeur zimmer est
rentré chez lui mais s'est retrouvé seul
sa famille avaient été arrêtés par les
nazis dans son appartement les affaires
de sa femme
les jouets de ses enfants mais il ne
savait pas s'il était encore en vie
beaucoup plus tard valeria soudainement
commencé à en parler pour la première
fois les allemands en fuyant chasser
tout le monde ait les amener avec eux
ils voulaient d'abord se cacher quelque
part dans une cave
mais ils ont entendu dire que des gens
s'étaient déjà cachées dans les caves
que les allemands les ont trouvés et les
fusillés donc ils ont eu peur bien sûr
alors ils ont été amenés je me souviens
comment valeria m'a dit un jour quand
mon fils andré et n'est pas sûr parce
les couches et je me suis étonné mais
valeria enfin et nous l'at elle dit on
lavait les couches avec de la neige
et puis les sécher sur nous-mêmes bac
c'était comme ça et puis il avait
toujours une petite photo de l'eeb sur
elle elle me disait quand un bon show
oui je prenais des risques parce qu'il
pouvait le voir il pouvait envoyer en
prison
elle disait aux signes je regardais avec
horreur mes enfants essayant d'évaluer
s'il avait des traits juifs ou non
je savais qu'on pouvait ne jamais
revenir je voulais que mes enfants
connaissent leur père
vous voyez comment elle était fort cette
femme
g après la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale la belle-mère de zilber lui a
rapporté une carte postale envoyée n'a
quand sa famille étaient en vie un belge
le plus tard après le retour et notre
rencontre c'était je crois en 1947 les
garçons était petit on allait tous à la
rivière et mois en raison de mon jeune
âge je suis immédiatement tombée
amoureuse de lèvres
je ne pouvais pas avoir empêché tout
simplement c'était un homme tellement
éloquent très charismatique très érudit
et doté d'un excellent sens de l'humour
on ne pourrait demander mieux
quand il était enfant il s'était
introduit dans un lycée de jeunes filles
vous savez comment il s'était déguisé en
pâtissier et une fois elle a fait une
blague
imaginez je me suis battu en duel et sa
mère demande lève comment ça pourquoi il
répond comment ça pour quoi
à cause d'une femme bien sûr
à la datcha de zilber on peut toujours
trouver les affiches confectionnées pour
les spectacles amateurs organisé à la
maison ni la guerre ni les camps n'ont
pu ébranler la joie de vivre de cette
famille
[Musique]
c'était un peu plus loin au delà du
village de vos rangs qui il y avait une
zone de sécurité donc on n'avait pas
permis à valeria et anastasia de vivre
là bas
vous vous rendez compte un académicien
un homme important il fallait déménager
il avait une vieille moskvich en mauvais
état
toute personne normale aurait demandé un
cheval avec une charrette n'est ce pas
mais non il prend une charrette la tâche
comme il peut à sa mosquée beach et nous
voilà tous assis sur cette charrette lui
au volant et nous allons tous en rien à
stepanovsky y est vous imaginez la
réaction des gens in most clic attelé à
une charrette
je trouve ça génial 1952 la sphère des
blouses blanches la lutte contre le
cosmopolitisme silber plaisantait ils
ont dû oublier de m'arrêter après la
guerre mais son sac était toujours prêt
dans son carnet il régnait à l'encré de
chine le nom des personnes qui pouvaient
aussi être arrêtés s'ils étaient de
nouveau emprisonné
et j'ai vu ce carnet je suis très fier
de le dire parce que il y avait des noms
rayés conneries chuck donc et quand il
est arrivé au nom de jet ski et chemine
l'air valérie a dit que tu les règles ou
non je suis tout le monde est déjà au
courant sur ce point mes parents étaient
très fiers il ya quelques années je
renouvelle mon appartement et un ouvrier
ma di maria qu'est-ce que vous avez là
il remplacer la ventilation
comme il ya plus de nos jours c'était un
vieil immeuble alors il me demande mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez là dans la
ventilation des torchons chef de jeu les
fourrées de torchon je couvrais le
téléphone avec des oreillers et
couvertures quand on parlait c'était
comme ça
pendant l'après guerre lève zilber et
ses collègues chercher des preuves
expérimentales de son hypothèse sur
l'origine des tumeurs ils étaient
impatients de terminer ses recherches
c'est difficile années de travail
acharné non sud détruire son talent ni
son caractère mais on affaiblit sa santé
[Musique]
il était très énergique
il avait une belle posture qui voit là
eh bien ça se sent ça se voit il se
tenait droit
on m'a dit qu'il pouvait même dansé la
mazurka alors même qu'il était déjà d'un
certain âge les robots stopper bien sûr
à ces conférences ont été suspendus à
ses mots en l'écouté en retenons notre
souffle
c'était un orateur remarquablement
locaux un jour je les croisais et il me
dit iata qui j'ai des virus très
intéressant en ce moment venez
travailler avec moi voilà vous comprenez
j'ai donc reçu une invitation
et puis après un certain temps quelqu'un
est arrivé en courant s'élève il va mal
je demande qu'est ce qui ne va pas et
puis je dis voici une bouillotte
mettez la sur ses pieds il n'a pas
survécu
aujourd'hui regardez tout scientifique
peut être fier s'il atteint dans l'une
de ses disciplines le niveau que les
gilbert avait atteint dans cinq ou six
disciplines différentes d'un stick
repêché astier race la microbiologie
immunologie oncologie biologie
moléculaire épidémiologie
l'oeuvre zilber a néanmoins réussi à
mener à terme le principal travail de sa
vie il accumulait les données
expérimentales conduisant à la
conclusion selon laquelle environ 20 %
des tumeurs sont causés chez l'homme par
des virus oncogènes cependant la
différence fondamentale entre les virus
oncogènes et les virus infectieux
conventionnelle et qu'on ne peut
contracter ces virus par contacts
humains
[Musique]
proche de plusieurs prix nobel ont été
attribués à partir des théories viraux
génétique de zilber le plus récent prix
nobel dans ce domaine a été attribué
pour la création d'un vaccin contre le
cancer du col de l'utérus aux espaces ok
en fait toutes les prémices de base
nécessaires pour créer ce vaccin et
comprendre la pathogénèse est énoncé
dans le travail de l'exil vers ce qu'il
a fait relève du patrimoine mondial et
appartient naturellement à toute
l'humanité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]